[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL YOUNG: So yeah.
Paul Young, as introduced.
For those of you who
haven't yet met me,
job title is Go-To-Market
Director for SAP Google Cloud
History.
Quickly is-- actually,
for some reason LinkedIn
has decided to auto generate
a post this week that says,
congratulate Paul on spending
one year at Google Cloud.
And so currently my
email has been bombarded
by people congratulating me.
So I guess I've been a year in
three days in role at Google.
Before that, 20 years at FCPA,
eight years at Hewlett-Packard
deploying, running their
FCP infrastructure.
So if you do math,
that means I'm old.
Right?
And we've come a long way in one
year, I'll tell you, at Google.
So just to give you an example
really quickly of where we are.
June last year at
Next San Francisco,
we announced that we'd have
the 12 and 18-terabytes VMs
available.
And it takes an act of God to
preannounce anything at Google,
I have to tell you.
In order to get that
to work, we actually
had to buy the hardware,
install it, and make
sure it ran, and would do
everything we claimed it would
before we were allowed
to preannounce it.
In our world it was
a pretty fixed event
that we'd committed
to launching these,
and we were going to launch
them, because we already
had the hardware.
That said, as obviously,
Brad announced this morning
in the keynote, the 12 and
the 6 are available right now
in early access to
customers, to become
fully available this half.
And so politely I'll
say promises made
and promises kept.
And at the time,
I'll tell you, there
was a lot of questioning
on whether we were going
to do this, because no one
had produced a VM bigger
than 4 terabytes at the time.
There was a question whether it
was even technically possible
and what it would do.
But we've delivered it.
And we've delivered on a plan
here with great intention,
and a plan that continues on.
And I wanted to just
fill in some gaps really
quickly here to explain why.
We've been obsessed with being
the only cloud provider that's
doing full-on VM for
our entire stack,
because we believe it opens up
huge potential for how you run
SAP and how you
can run that better
and how you can manage
the change that comes day
to day with running
SAP environments.
Just to give you
one quick example.
Brad talked about this earlier
as well in the environment.
We had a customer in the life
sciences space who came to us
and said, look.
One of our big
challenges is downtime.
Right?
The law being what the law
is right now that if you're
in the pharmaceutical business,
you're in the medical device
business, you fundamentally
can't manufacture
if SAP isn't online.
Right?
You're required to record
for pharmaceuticals
the ingredients that were
used, the recipe that was used.
And if it's not online,
you can't record that.
If you're building
pacemakers, you
have to record the battery
and who it came from
and what batch it came from, so
that in the event of a fault,
we can trace everybody who has
a pacemaker with that batch
of batteries installed in it.
And so literally, if
SAP isn't running,
then they have to shut
down the entire company
until it comes back up again.
So the CIO basically said, look.
We're a $10 billion
a year manufacturer
in the life sciences space.
And every hour where SAP is down
it cost us a million dollars.
And the answer was, if you
can do something about that,
then that's something
better, right?
And again, coming
back to why are we
VM-based, why do
we care about VMs?
We're VM-based and
we care about it
that much because
one of the things
we have is live migration.
Right?
So what happens is basically
that if we detect a patch needs
to be put in for
security purposes,
instead of what everybody
else on the planet does,
which is send you
an email saying,
you have 72 hours to
shut down your systems
and take a three-hour
outage while you patch
your environment, which is
$3 million in lost revenue
you weren't planning for.
What happens in our
world is, a brand new VM
powers up at exactly
the same size and shape
of what you're running.
It's pre-patched for security.
And then we replicate the
system across while it
runs-- the memory, the
CPU state, the disk.
And when we achieve sync,
your original drops out
and, you continue onwards.
And $3 million saved every time
we do that for one customer.
Right?
And up until now
nobody can do that.
Right now only we can do that.
Only we can do it for
anything over half a terabyte.
We're going all
the way up to 12.
And that graph's at 18.
Right?
The bigger you get, the
bigger the number is.
And so that's, I think,
the bit you first
want to understand about where
we're at in Google Cloud,
right?
Is we didn't enter
this market saying--
uncannily, when I came on
board, the conversation
was, hey, if we just want to
be a hosting provider for SAP,
then let's just go
buy a hosting company.
Right?
We don't want to be
a hosting provider.
We want to be the best
run environment for SAP.
And that's the
first step of that.
I'll give you a separate
example of where we're at.
One of the other things,
again, what everybody else has
to do right now is you have
to take a three-year commit
to an SAP server.
So you come through and you say,
hey, I have my plan for SAP.
From the beginning of
time, what SAP says
is we need to go
do a quick sizer.
And you need to tell me what
your busiest hour is going
to be three years from now.
And we're going to buy
all of that equipment,
and we're going to run it.
And hopefully you've
sized it correctly.
But you're going to run
all that equipment hoping
you get your growth rates right,
hoping you get your customer
demand right, and
everything else to where
you need to be in three years.
So I've done this conversation
a lot with the retailers.
My first question generally I
say in the retail conversations
is, does anyone know--
there's a risk here,
because I think
there is someone in the
audience who knows this.
So don't answer it.
But does anyone know
what the best-selling toy
was three years ago?
So Christmas 2015.
Anyone know what the
number one selling toy was?
No.
I've done this a lot.
Generally people don't know.
You can check me on
this, but I believe
the number one selling
toy Christmas 2015
was an Elsa doll.
And the fact that none
of us have remembered
that is indicative of how little
we know about history, never
mind the future.
Right?
If anyone can tell me what the
top selling toy is in 2022,
then we're both in
the wrong business.
Right?
And given that you can't do
that, the concept that you know
how big your SAP system needs
to be three years from now,
and you can contract with me
for that capacity, is ludicrous.
Right?
But it's what
everybody else does.
Except us.
Because we're virtual
machine-based.
So what you don't buy
from me is fixed machines.
What you buy from
me is capacity.
Right?
And if you need more than that
capacity two years from now,
it's OK.
You can just increase the
capacity that you need.
Right?
Likewise, what you're
looking at here
is a command where
we're basically
driving 15 terabytes of memory
and committing it in Frankfurt.
Let's say you need 12 terabytes.
But you don't need
12 terabytes now.
Right?
Right now you've got a bunch of
little dev boxes and everything
else.
So what you need right
now is 24 half terabytes.
Great.
Let's say tomorrow you
need 6 one terabyte
and 3 two terabytes.
Great.
Let's say the day after
you need 1 twelve terabyte.
Great.
You just restructure
as you need to.
No one's done that
flexibility before.
Right?
So there's my very quick state
of the union on where we are.
We made a lot of
promises last year
to customers where we said,
we're going to be different.
We're going to have the
best run environments.
Politely, we've delivered.
We've delivered on time.
And secondarily politely,
we've only just started.
There's a lot more to come.
But with that, I've
always said in this space
that SAP customers don't
actually buy from salespeople.
SAP customers buy
from SAP customers.
Generally it's a very
small but very active
tribe where when one does
one, and it's successful,
everybody else will learn
about it and will follow.
So objective for the year was,
first of all, land customers.
Secondary and politely, land
customers of significance.
Right?
So land the biggest
customers we can handle,
because the challenge
is you start small.
And the average SAP
customer will come along
and say, well, yeah.
They're in my industry, and
yeah, they're in my country.
But I'm bigger than them.
Can you really work?
There's always going
to be skepticism.
So the answer was, who are
the biggest customers--
in our dreams, who are the
biggest customers we could
possibly land that would
prove to this business
that we're serious, we're
here, we do the enterprise,
and we can do SAP at the
largest scale possible?
And one of my dream customers
on that list was McKesson.
And through good luck
and good fortune,
McKesson is a customer for SAP
for Google Cloud at this point.
So thank you for the business.
But once again, I could tell
you about this all afternoon.
It doesn't really matter.
Far more important
and far better
is for you to hear from
a customer themselves.
So I'd like to welcome on stage,
Meena Kishanchandani and Andy
Zitney from McKesson
[APPLAUSE]
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Hey, Paul.
That was almost a perfect
pronunciation of my last name.
PAUL YOUNG: I've been
dreading-- lately I've
been dreading that one all day.
I have to tell you.
I've was round the
back rehearsing.
You can correct me for--
your coming back tomorrow
for another event.
So.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: But no.
That was almost perfect.
PAUL YOUNG: I get points
for that one, apparently.
So thanks.
So both of you, A, thanks
for giving us the time.
Thanks for your
business, as always.
Generally, these
things, the tendency
is to want to talk
about technology.
Right?
We're at a technology
conference.
Frankly, in this space I believe
this is as much about people
as it is about technology.
So let's make this a
little more personal.
Do you want to--
can I give the audience
a little background
on your career path so far?
What gets you to your
current role at McKesson?
Who are you?
ANDY ZITNEY: Will I start?
I'll start.
So I'm Andy Zitney,
CPO from McKesson.
Background, a lot of financial
industry, including PayPal.
I see the PayPal contingent.
So a lot of stuff learned
from all of those episodes
with PayPal, JP
Morgan, Allstate.
I think Allstate was an
almost 70-year-old company.
And I thought that
wasn't old enough.
So I left there and joined
a 180-year-old company
in the health care
industry, and always
sort of ran toward the fire.
And I think in the
health care industry
a lot of the change
going on, not only with
the industry itself,
but also transformation
in the technology side
within that industry,
gave me a burning
platform to run toward.
And I decided to go
see what I could do.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
So Meena Kishanchandani.
And I have been with
McKesson for coming up
on almost 12 years.
And before McKesson I was
with a utility company
in the Midwest for a few years.
So I joined McKesson
as a database architect
having no background in SAP.
I joined an SAP technology team.
So very quickly
I kind of learned
that I need to cross over at
some point, because otherwise
I'm just not going to make it
double digits in the company.
So I did that.
And for a few years I did
more of a technical delivery,
hands-on support, all of
that for the SAP applications
that we have at McKesson.
In a few years I kind of
started leading the team.
And on my journey
at McKesson then
I've taken on also some data
analytics responsibilities.
And then most recently I've
kind of been asked to--
I've been tasked with leading
some of our ERP technology
transformation
workstream at McKesson.
So that's my current
role right now.
And focused on that ERP--
overall ERP transformation,
as well as our cloud journey
for those applications as well.
PAUL YOUNG: Cool.
So let's start the baseline for
the people in the audience who
don't know McKesson.
Let's just hit the background
on what is McKesson.
ANDY ZITNEY: So if you take
a look at McKesson being I
mentioned a 180-year-old
plus company,
it basically is centered
around pharma distribution.
About 80,000 employees
in 14 countries, or so.
Depends on the time and
how many acquisitions
we're going through how
will I answer that question.
Also, it's about $210
billion in revenue.
So when you're looking
at the Fortune list,
we're somewhere in that
top five or six list.
And if you think about it from
a distribution perspective,
we handle one out of every three
medical units of distribution
in the United States.
So anything in the
hospital, whether it's
a drug or med surg
device, we've touched it
one out of every three.
And we're having a
technical problem.
PAUL YOUNG: That's great.
Went double-fisted on
the slide controller.
There you go.
That'll work.
OK.
Can we go back two?
ANDY ZITNEY: Hit the button.
PAUL YOUNG: And one more.
Perfect.
ANDY ZITNEY: Did
I miss anything?
Over 275,000 SKUs, it
says up on the slide.
So this is really who we are.
So when you think about
from an SAP perspective
and the landscape, you're
looking about 22 data centers
globally.
We may not be the largest
SAP implementation.
But what's out
there, and everybody
keeps talking
about is, we're one
of the highest
transaction processing SAP
environments in the world.
But it's-- Meena will go
into a lot more of this.
It's a very complex
environment because we've
grown through acquisition.
So it's not a single instance
or anything nice and clean
like that.
It's a bunch of them
sort of taped together.
PAUL YOUNG: I always think--
I mean, I visited McKesson a
few times with my SAP badge
on before I came visiting
with my Google badge on.
I mean, the thing that
always struck me is--
and I know we'll come back to
this in Meena's conversation--
but yeah.
If you guys catch a cold, the
world has a problem, basically.
I mean, fundamentally-- when we
started into this, it's funny.
Google, they said, well, what do
we need to know about McKesson?
And my answer is, look.
Imagine your local hospital.
And you know, understand
all the supplies,
all the pharmaceuticals, all the
bandages, all the saline bags,
everything that's
required every day,
and then realize that you
don't have warehouses attached
to them, which they should.
Right?
Well, they don't because these
guys are the warehouse, really.
You know, you place an order
for any medical product,
and 40 hours later it will be
delivered anywhere in America
or throughout Europe.
I mean, literally, if
something goes wrong,
the world of health
care has a problem.
It's just amazing what you do
and the skill you do it at.
You're a critical part of
the economy, ultimately.
ANDY ZITNEY: It's
critical infrastructure
for the health care industry.
Right.
And everything that we push
out of distribution centers
are cleared out within
a couple of hours.
So it's really like having our
distribution centers online 24
by 7 around the country.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah.
So with that, I
mean, health care
is a fascinating
industry to be in.
But it's an industry that's
changing really quickly, right?
ANDY ZITNEY: Fascinating.
That's a good word for it.
It is a fascinating
industry to be in right now,
because everything is changing.
It's not unlike
any other industry.
But I think it's getting
it from multiple fronts.
You're having the
disruptions from your non--
I'll say your
non-legacy players--
everybody thinks of
Amazon and others--
entering in the space,
thinking that it's regulatory
and it was protected isn't
such the case anymore.
There's a lot of
entries coming in.
And then when you take a look
at the government getting
involved with the
health care industry,
and especially when you
think about it running it
in the EU or the UK region
and some of the government
involvement there and how they
influence everything in health
care, and then just
pile on top of there
the shift from what I'll say
is the legacy health care
experience that we have
today, moving toward--
away from-- generic
drugs and moving more
toward specialty drugs that
are really a drug manufactured
particularly for you,
your DNA, and trying
to get that from
the manufacturer
basically into your body
as fast as possible.
That's a whole different
distribution problem
than what we solved for with
the generics distribution.
PAUL YOUNG: So change
comes everyday.
And so with that I think one
of the interesting things,
Andy is--
I know you've been on the
conference tour a lot recently.
So once again, thanks
for your time here.
But I know a year ago
in the conversations
I was having with SAP customers
and Cloud customers in general,
the theme was always lift
and shift, lift and shift.
And I'll tell you, so
far this year there's
been very little conversation
about lift and shift.
Is this the understanding at
this point that running it here
to running it there, there
may be some economies.
But ultimately it's about
the ability to handle change,
it's about the next
generation architecture.
Right?
I know you have strong
feelings about this.
So how do you feel?
ANDY ZITNEY: Yeah,
this is really
where sort of the architecture
conversation came in,
and really where we got
Google brought to the table.
And the dialogue and
the conversation for me
was, how do we solve the ERP?
Right?
For SAP for us, everything
else is going to follow.
So whatever we do with that
sort of sitting in the center,
about 90% of our
universe is going
to follow that
application suite however
we architect that solution.
What this is is really
the target architecture.
Basically what we said was--
and my team takes offense to
this-- but below the value
line, above the value line.
Right?
We want to operate
and deliver as much
of that below the value line
so that's value to the customer
and just have that delivered.
Pick a partner.
Pick a partner that has
the culture that you
want to fit your target
culture for your organization
and your company.
Bring them to the table.
They have the right solutions.
You've heard about
the jumbo VMs.
Right?
That was a major
separation for us
when we were looking
for the partners,
because we knew we had to solve
for that large SAP environment.
It just wasn't a net new, build
fresh type of environment.
You had to solve for
the purchase packages.
So what we looked at was
really plowing everything
into partners below the line,
bring the right strategy
and strategic partners
to that below line,
and then allow our employees
to operate above the line.
Right?
So if you're thinking,
like, GCPA Sutton S4 on GCP,
that gives us an
environment that we can then
release some of our
internal employees
to be software
engineers above the line
to do things like data analytics
on top of that platform.
And that's our whole strategy
So as opposed to for
the last five years
I think a lot of companies
were just taking everything
and saying, hey, let's
run it in the cloud.
And we'll do the lift and shift.
So they ran it.
And they ran it the same way.
It was the same application.
It wasn't refactored.
And it was sitting on really
expensive infrastructure
as a service architecture.
That's not at all
what we want to do.
We want to refactor
the applications
and put in an
architecture that allows
us to add value above
that line to the customer
and not pay too much
attention to what's below.
PAUL YOUNG: Cool.
And million/billion dollar
question in this case,
because I'm sure there's
a bunch of people sitting
in this audience and beyond
watching the replay as
well who's answer is, OK.
That sounds like a great vision.
I want to get there.
And I want to get there
isn't necessarily just
sign a contract with GCP.
It's also you're persuading the
executive tier in the company
to want to buy into
that vision too.
How do you-- I
mean, you and me met
to start this process last
June at lunch at Next.
Right?
In the nine months
since, just give us
a highlight of what
you had to go through
to get to where we are now.
ANDY ZITNEY: No, it's a bit
of a perfect storm, too.
SAP.
Our current environment.
When does it end of life?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: 2025.
ANDY ZITNEY: 2025 end of life.
We also have J. Edwards
in the environment.
It's coming end of life too.
So we have a perfect
storm in and around
what we're going to be touching.
So the real selling
point was, we want
to do this a lot different.
So if we move toward
this target architecture,
you're going to be touching
about 80% of your plant
from an application
suite perspective.
You're going to be
touching it anyway.
So let's do this
significantly different.
The selling point of
the why at that point
became a conversation
around enabling speed
to value for the business.
Because what they feel
today is a very methodical--
I'll say, like,
enterprise release type
of planning where
when they think
of the product or the
enhancement, it's six, nine,
12 months before
they can actually
see it in the environment.
We go to this
architecture, and there's
a lot more to this architecture
than just GCP, the API
architecture, and
everything else
that enables it to
move with speed.
But once you have
that in place, they
can think about the
enhancement and start
putting it in within weeks,
hopefully within days.
PAUL YOUNG: And this is
probably the scope of what
we're doing with McKesson.
It isn't limited to SAP.
Right?
ANDY ZITNEY: No.
It's very holistic.
Right?
It's an entire ecosystem.
PAUL YOUNG: Entire ecosystem.
You said.
That's a big ecosystem.
Speaking of which,
Meena, I know again
when I spent my time
with [INAUDIBLE]
by joining McKesson, it's
a high priority customer.
There's very few bigger
and very few more critical.
But do you want to
just give the audience
an understanding of the sort
of scope we're talking about?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Sure.
I wish our actual
ecosystem looked
as clean and neat as it looks
on the slide, to be honest.
But it is a pretty
fairly large ecosystem.
And we have more
than 25-plus products
deployed already across
multiple countries,
including 13 countries in
Europe and US and Canada.
And we have an S4
implementation going on in UK
as well, for which we'll be
deploying I think six or even
more products there.
So when it comes to the number
of environments we have,
we have almost
60-plus landscapes.
I could not get
a definite number
because it's
ever-changing, as anybody
who works with SAP knows,
especially the technology team.
And then 260-plus instances.
So does n plus 1--
for many landscapes, that's
an n plus 1 landscape as well.
And just in North America,
one of four ECC systems
that services our pharmaceutical
distribution business unit,
it's 100-plus terabytes.
So if you think about
the number of systems
that are copies of
production in the landscape,
you're touching almost--
just for that one landscape,
it's close to at least,
I would say, half a petabyte.
And on top of that, you
add secondary storage
where we have--
very proactively archived data--
business data.
So that's pretty huge as well.
And then you add the
multiple copies of backups
and other kind of
archives and all of that.
It's a pretty large
storage footprint, just
for that one instance.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yeah.
And then that
particular instance also
is a very high volume
transaction processing
system, upwards of close to--
up to 2 million
line items a day.
So you can imagine
the complexity
involved to support that large
of an environment as well.
We're also a pretty mature
Hana shop, I would say.
We have multiple Hana
deployments as well.
We have a 24-terabyte
BW in Hana environment.
We have a 6-terabyte
suite on Hana
with [INAUDIBLE]
add-on environment.
And a 4 terabyte VPC
on Hana environment.
And that's just naming
some of them out there.
So we have a large talent
pool that understands Hana
pretty well, and so is
kind of getting ramped up
for the next
generation of our ERP.
Currently, as I
mentioned, I think
we have our UK as for
implementation and flight.
And it is actually
started on GCP.
And with all of that I
think we can safely say
we are amongst the top five.
You know, I'm not [INAUDIBLE].
I guess.
I think it's up on
that scale of 1 to 5.
But I think to be safe
I'll say it's top 5.
PAUL YOUNG: I think
you're safely in top five.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yeah.
PAUL YOUNG: [INAUDIBLE]
That's the reason why
I love you, cause the--
every day we deal with
the question of, yeah.
But who do you have
that's bigger than me?
And generally the
answer, McKesson
is [INAUDIBLE] GCP generally
ends that conversation.
There's not many people
bigger than McKesson.
I think the point,
just really quickly,
it says 2 million lines a day.
[INAUDIBLE] the thing
that was slightly
fascinated me and terrified
me about McKesson is,
it's a granular business.
I mean, that order doesn't
say, just go to the warehouse
and grab a bottle of
pharmaceuticals and ship it.
It tells you the specific
bottle of pharmaceuticals.
So it's so serialized,
there's a huge amount
of compute power involved
in making those decisions
and making health care
traceable and correct.
Right?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Yeah, exactly.
And these line items.
I mean, it's actually bulk of
it is processed in a four to six
peak hour window.
So when you talk about
compute, I mean, you really
have to design for
that peak workload.
And if you think about the--
especially in the
products and our specialty
for plasma and
biologic space, you
think about the absolute
end point customer sitting
there waiting for the product.
I mean, you can
imagine what kind
of availability
requirement we have,
and also, what kind of
performance and throughput
requirement we have here.
And this is just
one environment.
So, it's like, so yeah.
So it is pretty
complex, I would say.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah.
So given that scope--
clearly that's answer--
hey, let's just run
a migration tool
and get it all over
there by next Tuesday.
Right?
You've got to
structure this down.
So the cart in front of
me says what's the plan
to eat the elephant, basically?
But I mean, how do you
plan to break this down?
How do you plan to kind
of structure this across?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
So I think starting
with a net new implementation
that's going on in UK
is the perfect start, where
we learn from that process,
and we are starting directly
on the cloud itself.
And some of my
enterprise principles
around keeping
the ERP core clean
and taking not actually--
not building customizations
in there in the ERP
platform itself,
and building them as
side-by-side extensions using
GCP services and using
some other technologies--
cloud modern technologies.
I think that's going to help us
actually plan our North America
kind of journey.
And because lifting and shifting
of our current environment,
I don't think we can
even move this one
landscape that I talked
about to actually GCP itself.
So that's the plan, that
we learn from there.
And then we take
those learnings,
bring them back,
and incorporate them
as part of our North America
ERP transformation journey.
PAUL YOUNG: OK.
So you and me were
in Stuttgart along
with a bunch of other
Google and McKesson people--
four weeks ago now?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Early March.
First week of March.
[INAUDIBLE]
PAUL YOUNG: You have a better
memory than I do, apparently,
of dates.
So yeah.
Right about four or five weeks
ago to get this all started.
What have you learned so far?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: A lot.
Yeah.
So--
PAUL YOUNG: Well, I
suppose it starts weak,
because we did a sort of
work with you before in terms
of testing reliability
and failover
and DR. So it starts before
Stuttgart by [INAUDIBLE]..
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Yeah, yeah.
So I think our journey
actually started
with you guys late October,
November last year.
And the perfect--
I mean, it was at the time
the implementation in Europe
that I'm talking about, they
had to make some decisions
around procuring hardware
fought for that implementation.
And also we had this
evaluation going on
for our primary cloud partner.
So it was the
perfect opportunity
to bring that use case
in and actually kick off
a POC of sorts.
And I think that POC was about a
four to six week PLC where we--
everything from soup
to nuts, we kind of
were able to stand up
and ask for environment.
At that point, we didn't even
have any network connected
with McKesson data centers.
So from networking
point onwards, I think--
and then there was about--
I want to say about 15 to
20 technical, operational
criterion that we had put down.
And they were pretty extensive.
Things like backups,
restores, system copies,
moving, you know, scaling
on the fly, live migration.
And there's a bunch of others
that we actually made those
as our success criterias.
And from that point onwards,
based on the successful outcome
of that particular
POC, we've then
made those decisions that
our UK SAP implementation
will start on GCP.
And then we have had a workshop
to enable the platform enough
to get this
implementation started.
And then early March is
where-- the first week
of March we had a
hackathon over there where
prior to the hackathon we
did a training for the teams
there so that they could come
and actually be productive
as in actively participate
and build things
there with the teams.
I think your team was there,
and then the PSO, and the TAM.
So there was a pretty
wide representation
from Google over there.
And so within three days
we were able to stand up,
I think, for SAP systems.
We did also spend time on
building some automation there
and not just manually
kind of deploying.
So achieving all of
that in three days,
I think, it's been phenomenal.
And since then those
teams have been
enabled enough to continue
those deployments on their own.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah.
Andy and me talked
the week after,
and Andy's [INAUDIBLE] was--
I think his exact words--
I'll quote [INAUDIBLE].
"I don't know what
Kool-Aid you give them,
but they certainly drank it."
I'll take that response
from a customer any day.
But that's--
ANDY ZITNEY: Like I said,
this was the big hurdle--
talking internal at McKesson was
getting the ASAP, what I'll say
is the heritage or legacy
SAP contingents sold off
on or bought off on that
we could actually do this,
because that wasn't an easy
conversation when we started it
internally a couple
of years ago.
PAUL YOUNG: I think this is
one of the challenges, right?
When you-- I mean an SAP talent
at this point is hard to find.
A lot of it is retiring
off this huge demand for it
as we go through this
round of upgrades.
So part of the
plan here has to be
to kind of keep people engaged.
So I asked one of the
questions we get a lot here,
which is, people don't
always react well to change.
And this is change.
And so can you make
it change in a way
that it actually engages people
and carries them through.
So coming back to the hackathon
and that sort of stuff,
do you think--
what can we do to
keep people engaged
and make this a project
they want to work on?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
I think it's just
about the art of the
possible, showing them
that vision as to
what's really possible.
Because they are-- even
talented in the SAP space
is also looking to really expand
and become more cloud aware.
And also, kind of
think of new solutions
that you can augment and
bring into the SAP environment
itself.
So to be able to--
so the more we can
enable them, the more we
can help them show the vision.
I think that would
be actually really--
that's the path to success.
PAUL YOUNG: Especially--
cause I had a conversation.
I actually had lunch with
another customer as well.
And it's something
you'd raised up
to me before, which is, I
think, part of the challenge
is as people tend to benchmark
what they do right now
against what they'll
do in the future.
And part of the
conversation is, how can you
get them to a point of
what's possible now, And?
Then how they can go from there?
And it's that moving
people's mindset to know
instead of who they were.
I think that's one of
the things that-- one
of the things that
fascinated me,
I have to say about
the Stuttgart is.
We saw a choice of
things very quickly
the McKesson elbowed
us out of the way,
because they wanted
to do it themselves.
They wanted to own
it and take it over.
And it was fascinating
to me how quickly
that happened in the room.
And yeah.
I mean, all credit
to you both of you
know the same team for the
enthusiasm and the excitement
I see at McKesson, right?
Is that fair in terms of the--
ANDY ZITNEY: I think you
guys delivering the engineers
to the room and
getting the engineers
sitting together and talking.
Nothing against all the
sales team that's here.
But getting the engineers in
the room and working together,
they got excited themselves.
And once she could
see them start
to think on the whiteboards
and start walking through this,
that became the art
of the possible.
And then layer on there a lot
of the automation conversations
that came into play.
Right?
I think that was a big
differentiator when
we were taking a look
at the partner, right?
Google comes in with a software
engineering mindset first.
And not a lot of the
others out there did.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah.
Very cool.
One of my favorite questions and
Andy's least favorite question.
Two, three, five years from
now, how do we measure success?
How do we know we've
been successful?
You're gonna say, Meena, can
you answer that question?
ANDY ZITNEY: Yeah.
I was gonna say.
Meena goes first.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
So I think every year
that success criteria
is going to change.
So I'm only thinking one
year at a time at this time.
So for me, over the next year,
it's quantitative, qualitative.
So if we can get our SAP
Europe implementation,
S4 implementation, the
production deployed
and working, and where
there's great user experience,
both from IT and
our business users.
I think that's a huge--
that's a number
one, in my opinion,
because that is our
opportunity to really sell--
you know, basically
convince everybody else
that this is going to work.
I think the other thing
is, if you can drastically
reduce our reliance on
our external partners,
including Google, where
our people can do things
on their own, because they're
really kind of ramped up.
I think that's
another one for me.
And I think finally, the third
one is that for North America,
if it can move the
dial forward and get
some of our SAP cloud-ready
type environments
successfully migrated.
I think for me, that's like--
I'm just looking
one year at a time,
because I don't even want to
think about it beyond that.
ANDY ZITNEY: I'll
start with where
I started last
night, that I didn't
get fired because of this.
So that's where the bar sets.
And then we go above that
and say a couple of things.
I think the customer
experience has to change.
Right?
This can't just be the
exact same environment.
So it has to be an
environment that
enables us to change
the business process,
enable business process
change in a simplistic manner
and add pace.
And get the business
to the table
thinking a lot different
than what we do today.
And leveraging this environment
and the capabilities
within the environment
that gives the business
an opportunity to think
differently on enhancements,
as opposed to I go back to
that comment I made earlier,
when you start thinking
about enhancement or change
or customization, that's
a long process today
in the current environment.
It'll be nice when they're
sitting at the table
and it's an easy conversation.
Says, you know, I
would really like
to just change this and do
that in a different manner.
Can we look at that?
And we give them an
environment where,
yeah, tell me that on a Monday,
and we can do it on a Friday.
And they say, yeah.
That's exactly what I want.
And then we go live
to production, right?
So it's enabling the business
to think much differently
than what they do today in a
huge environment and a much
hopefully much more
simplistic environment
when we implement it.
And then the last
thing I'd say is,
Meena mentioned
keep the core hull.
For us, that really means
all customizations-- well,
a lot of the customizations,
90% of the customizations--
are done on our custom
platform and not built
into the core
purchased application.
That gives us massive
change in the architecture.
That would give us
upgradability, sustainability
to the core, and much less
cost to maintain, and enable
the business enhancements at
our pace with our resources.
PAUL YOUNG: I think it's
interesting, actually,
that the change thing
has started to come up
with customers who've been with
us for a while, because again,
in that VM-based
world, historically
one of the things against
SAP is you can't change.
Right.
And not that you can't
change, but you have an idea.
But it's got to fit into the
change control mechanism.
And so you want to justify it.
And it takes a while.
And you have to end
up to scale them up.
And that ability to do small
incremental change that
would make a huge
difference just
isn't there in the platform.
And a lot of that is driven
by hardware constraint.
Right?
We've see this a couple
customers have said, look,
I can just copy off a QA system.
I can try my concept.
If I like it, it's good.
I could approved it
and I can roll it in.
And that ability
to kind of unlock
the capacity of organization
to change and innovate
is fascinating.
Right?
It opens up a potential
in SAP that's not there.
The other thing I'd
just add in really
quickly is, on your
above the line,
below the line
discussion, for some
of the customers that
have been with us a
while, there's one in particular
where I chased the CIO down
a show recently, where I
said, I just want to check in
that everything's going OK.
Right?
Because I haven't
heard from you.
And his answer was, look.
I've had-- I've been
live for nine months,
and I've had zero
incidents where
we've had to call Google Cloud.
And he said, on the one
hand, it's fantastic.
On the other hand,
you know, I see
a lot of my other salespeople,
because their system breaks.
And I call them
and chat with them.
And then we talk
about other stuff.
Right?
He's like, I never have to
call you to shout at you,
so we never talk.
And nice problem to have.
However, it's
fascinating, because it's
one of the things I
think long term we're
going to have chase through.
As much as the
hackathon and everything
is really good where we're
having to invest and get
your people to speak.
I think ultimately
the conversation
I've had with a
bunch of other CIOs
is, ultimately they want us
to effectively be invisible.
Right?
They want us to be a utility
that's just there and works
and [INAUDIBLE] happens.
And so I think we're still
finding their way in terms
of how do you engage
with the customer,
contribute, make
them successful,
but equally know
when to back off
and then leave them with
us in the utility space.
Does that make sense in your
above the line, below the line?
ANDY ZITNEY: Yeah.
And it's-- the whole dynamic
above and below that value line
is, that line was
flat in that drawing.
It's definitely not flat.
Right?
So it goes across a bunch
of business capabilities.
And depending on the
business capability
is depending on where you want
to draw that line, in my mind.
Right?
Because you could draw
that line very low and say,
there is a lot above that
line that adds value,
and it's a differentiator
in the business.
So let's have more money
invested above that line.
There's others that
for core services--
and I think SAP core
services is one of those--
there's a lot below that line.
There's a ton below that line.
And we would like to get that
to your point as a commodity,
and just deliver
it to the business.
Then let them think of
things like pricing engines
and everything else
above that line,
and put all their focus up
there as opposed to us talking
to them about we have an upgrade
coming, we have a patch coming,
we're going to have
an outage for it.
And everything else.
They shouldn't have those
conversations anyway.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yeah.
For example, to add an upgrade
today in one of the largest
environment that I'm talking--
I talked about, it takes
anywhere between 9 to 12 to 18
months, and millions
and millions
of dollars of investment
because of how complex
it is and all of the stuff
that we've built on top of it
over the years.
PAUL YOUNG: Like, I said
earlier, stay tuned.
But as you're aware, we've
got some other stuff.
We're not done innovating yet.
How about that for an answer?
On that I shall say no
more before PR mugs me.
For both of you, I would
say we're a year on.
We're effectively
nine months on.
What do you know
now that you wish
you knew nine months ago when
you were starting this process?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
So I think I'm not
sure about the nine months.
But it's-- I'd probably go
back to the experience with--
at least I've had,
or my team has had--
on working with
the cloud on some--
even prior to those nine months.
So our journey, I'm sure at
McKesson, has been on for 4
some years?
And some of the SAP folks
have been also trying
to build some capabilities for
at least a couple of years.
So I'll go back
to that reference
point and not the nine
months reference point.
So it has to be obviously,
it's a no-brainer that you have
to kind of invest
in your people,
because traditional ways
of thinking sometimes
takes time to change.
Then you have to really
kind of ramp up quickly
to get some change going.
I think you have to partner
with the external expertise
and experience as well while
your staff is coming up.
Talk to customers who
have done this before.
And then from a
process perspective,
I'd say really
invest in automation.
Assess what your team is
spending the most time
on doing manual tasks.
Those are candidates for
automation from day one.
So definitely that
should be your focus
as you're thinking
about moving to cloud.
The other thing that comes to
mind is challenge this 24 by 7
assumptions for some of your
non-production environments,
because it's not as--
ANDY ZITNEY: Tough for a period.
And I think there's also
something [INAUDIBLE]
to speed at the end of the
day, because it does clean up
your environment,
and you don't have
to worry about all
the integration
points at the end of the day.
PAUL YOUNG: It is fascinating.
Because again, if you define it
as lift and shift, it's easy.
It's just the stuff that's
there it's over there.
It's just a SpongeBob
meeting, basically, right?
The point where you
realize that you
can get additional
value from it,
it's a lot more thinking, right?
ANDY ZITNEY: Yeah.
PAUL YOUNG: And it's not a
technical problem anymore.
It's not just a--
hey, here's a tool,
and you can move it.
There's a lot more--
it's a project.
Right?
It involves business
people and changing
people's lives and everyone
else has had much more work.
Last question says, well
again, nine months ago we all--
a group of people
had lunch from here.
That's where we started.
Not where you guys started.
And now we're here.
Equally, there's
a bunch of people
sitting in this
audience who likely
are here for the first time
having lunch and thinking
about getting started.
What would you tell them?
Other than enjoy lunch.
ANDY ZITNEY: I would say, how
do you get started is just that.
Go get started.
I guess, Mike, I would
answer it with a question.
Well, what's plan B?
What's your other options?
Is it like for like and
maintaining the same?
And I think if
that's your answer,
you may want to rethink it.
Because the business is going
to look at as more the same
and slow down.
And I think you'll have
a different conversation
with your business.
You go to them with
a strategy that
is demonstrating not necessarily
that value line slide,
but demonstrating
that conversation
that you really are trying to
free up the company's resources
to plow into that.
The differentiating business
processing above that line,
and this is how we think we
can do it and articulate it.
I think it's a much
better conversation,
and they'll be more
eager to get started.
PAUL YOUNG: Meena?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think-- I think
most of what Andy said
is what I'm thinking as well,
because like for like is really
there's no business case
there, to be honest.
As least if you're like
McKesson or even close to it,
it's just not going to work.
So you have to be open to
kind of re-architecting your--
not just from a
technology perspective,
but also your kind
of not quite culture,
I would say, but
how the messaging
that goes from top
down to the people
and how you energize
the base as well.
Because that's, I think, one
of the most important things
that if they're not
[INAUDIBLE],, then
that's going to be
tough to achieve.
PAUL YOUNG: Once again,
thank you for your business.
Thank you for your time.
Sincerely, I really
do appreciate
you taking time for sharing
your wisdom with everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]